disparos al aire y fuegos artificiales
sobre el cielo de kabul
los talibanes celebraron su victoria
definitiva en afganistán desde el primer
minuto del 31 de agosto en la madrugada
entraron al aeropuerto de la capital
afgana controlado durante las últimas
semanas por el ejército de eeuu como
símbolo de su triunfo sobre una de las
fuerzas militares más poderosas del
mundo
primero felicito a toda la nación porque
hemos logrado nuestra independencia y
pudimos obligar a los estadounidenses a
irse después de 20 años de yihad y
sacrificio esta independencia es de toda
la nación y todo nuestro pueblo es
involucrado en ella han sufrido penurias
en estos 20 años los felicito a todos
los talibanes prometieron que su
victoria traerá paz y estabilidad
durante la primera reunión después de la
retirada y aseguraron que sus tropas
controlarán el aeropuerto para
garantizar su seguridad
la quietud y el silencio se apoderaron
de las instalaciones ya que los
talibanes no tienen la capacidad de
operar el puente aéreo el nuevo régimen
busca el apoyo de turquía para hacerlo
funcionar y por ahora ha prometido que
los vuelos comerciales se retomarán tan
pronto como sea posible
de esa promesa depende la vida de muchos
afganos colaboradores de los gobiernos y
ejércitos de la otan que no lograron ser
evacuados desde bruselas llegan palabras
de aliento
no los olvidaremos y seguiremos
trabajando por su derecho a irse de
manera segura y ordenada medio alba son
fuertes estando selectos aliados de la
otan demostraron su compromiso en ayudar
a salir a la gente evacuando a más de
120 mil personas
palabras todavía en concretas mientras
los líderes de los gobiernos
occidentales reorganizan su estrategia
ahora que todo ha cambiado en afganistán